Film Courage: How do you feel about the quality
of storytelling you’re seeing today?
Jack Perez, Director: I mean…that’s a
good question.
How do I feel about the quality?
I don’t know?
I’m not really attracted to a lot of new
stuff.
I think because I’ve seen a lot of it before
and that’s just my personal thing.
I think at this point it’s just an age thing
and it’s a result of being a film nerd because
when you consume as much cinema as I have
in my lifetime you have seen (in most cases)
the best iterations or story or genre already.
So when I see something new that just manages
to be good execution or well executed story
that I’ve already seen it’s not enough
for me already.
So I find myself going back to the films that
have really changed my life, that really did
it best because I want to be nourished because
in that way.
It’s not enough for me to see something
that is just a really good yarn that was well-directed
and well-produced even though that’s a monumental
feat (any filmmaker will tell you that making
a good movie is a miracle).
But for me personally I tend to look to the
past for the inspiration because I feel like
in most cases it was done best and that doesn’t
mean that I’m resistant to somebody showing
me something that is truly brilliant because
I would welcome that.
If somebody showed me something that was earth
shatteringly brilliant better than anything
else then I would be like be like “Jesus
Christ!
Thank you!”
And I want to see that stuff and I’m sure
it’s out there, I’m sure it’s out there.
I just haven’t seen anything lately.
Film Courage: Well I know THE HANDMAID’S
TALE, it was a movie with Elizabeth McGovern,
was it the eighties I think?
Or early nineties was it?
Jack: Yes?
The movie?
You mean the original HANDMAID’S TALE?
Film Courage: And so now…now…it’s got
a whole new life to it and they are spoofing
it on Saturday Night Life.
But back then I don’t know if I had actually
heard a lot about it.
Jack: I think it was in the eighties.
I was actually an intern at the production
company where they were making that movie.
I remember Xeroxing…f*cking up the Xerox.
I forget who was the director of that, a German
director?
But anyway it was in New York City, I was
like a PA in the office and they were having
this special lunch meeting or something and
I was in charge of getting the new draft together
and I was like printing this thing out and
it was just jammed in the printer and I ran
over to 21 or wherever they were having dinner
and I remember giving it to the producer and
it was like all the pages were out of order
and he was looking at me judgmentally and
I was like “I’m f*cked, I’m never going
to work in this business again.”
Well like a good story that a filmmaker or
a writer finds a way in or changes it or makes
it more contemporary or more resonate or personal
(whatever it is) I think that’s totally
valid, too.
But I haven’t seen much recently.
Film Courage: It’s kind of like a band that
does like…When the Levee Breaks and it’s
like okay…it sounded so much better when
Robert Plant sang it.
But now you’re doing it but it just doesn’t
have the same appeal…but again is it a generational
thing because you and I were just talking
off camera about video discs and seeing even
nineties films that had a different feel to
it.
Jack: Well I think that’s true.
I talk to my students about this all the time.
I think it’s an amazing age and it’s a
horrible age.
It’s amazing in the sense that anything
that you want to see in the history of the
world is available like that.
Gone are the days of hunting for a revival
house that is going to be showing THE THIRD
MAN or SEVENTH SAMURAI or what have you or
anything for that matter.
It’s not that you have to hunt for a video
store (not that they exist anymore) that is
going to carry a special John Woo Hong King
action thing, one that you can’t find.
Everything is available at any given moment.
That said there is so much material, there
is so much available that I wouldn’t know
where to begin.
And I think that that’s a problem because
unless there is somebody (a teacher or film
geek parent) that is saying “Spend your
time watching this…this…this and this
before you watch this other stuff because
that’s going to educate you, that’s going
to make you a better filmmaker.”
Then you’re bound to lose those great things
and I’m not even talking about the obvious
classics, I’m just talking about the minor
films that are still better than the junk
you see today, you’re never going to see
them because there’s just too much to look
at.
I’m sort of losing the thread of the question
but my feeling now is there is almost too
much to see and it’s almost as if you need
to graduate, that there is a prerequisite.
You have to watch all this stuff if you want
to be a filmmaker and then you can watch as
much junk as you want that is out now.
Film Courage: Right well a lot of stuff seems
over processed, too over-produced in some
ways?
And maybe just as a culture we’ve become
use to that so if it’s not packaged that
way we don’t want it?
Jack: I think you’re right, we were talking
about this earlier.
If social media is overproduced (if someone’s
personal Instagram page with all it requisite
filters and glamour and the tools of production
in the hands of anybody, it raises this level,
this standard of what’s acceptable to a
professional level in such a way.
But it also creates a certain artifice.
One of my favorite quotes that John Cassavetes
said about Hollywood films in general is that
“They are an advertisement for life.”
That what he said “Hollywood movies in most
cases are an advertisement for life.
Whereas my films which are clearly, comparatively
very rough and mistakenly looked upon as almost
amateurish compared to that polish and mistakenly
because that was by design because he was
a professional.
He made these films look a certain way.
Because he was trying to get to something
that was the opposite, he was trying to get
at the messiness, the reality of life.
Whereas Hollywood almost by definition tries
to minimize that in favor of this gloss or
polish or illusion.
And that becomes the diet that you’re consuming.
If you see something that is gritty or messy
or whatever and I’m not even talking about
the look.
I’m talking about the content, where the
content is not just this clearly, safe, defined
thing.
People may have a resistance to that where
they may go “This is too much.
I don’t want this.
This is not the food I’ve chosen to eat.”
But what does it do to you tastes?
It limits your taste to only want this candy
and not something that is more substantial
in that way…nourishing.
Film Courage: I was just watching part of
THE STEPFORD WIVES.
Jack: Which one?
The original.
Film Courage: Yes.
And just like the long driving sequence beginning
with all the credits and the classic early
seventies music that we would hear all the
time and now it sounds so wonderful but every
show and movie had it.
But just in terms of how quiet it is.
There are just moments where nothing is happening
every second, it’s breathing.
Jack: Yes and I’ve always said this and
anybody will tell you this that the strength
of a spike in story or movie where somebody
goes crazy, there’s a lot of kinetic activity
or surprise or whatever is directly related
to the quiet that precedes it.
In other words something is super loud or
big relative to what preceded it.
So that’s why in a horror movie (they learned
this going back to the 1930’s) but if you
have a very quiet almost nothing happening
and then a huge scare, that scare becomes
magnified.
Whereas if you have to maintain what is now
the classic, Hollywood mantra of just a thrill
every second, then that thrill every second
becomes a plateau, you just become accustomed
to it.
It’s not going to hit you the same way then
if you allowed for that quiet to proceed it.
But that assumes that the audience…well
it probably assumes that the producers are
will to allow that quiet to happen and not
be “Oh sh*t!
People are going to be bored, we have to do
something exciting.
We can’t have this length of quiet.”
And that the audiences are willing to invest
in that, be okay with that.
And to say “This is not boring.
This is interesting.”
And then be the beneficiary of the result
of that if something huge follows that because
it will be huger because of it.